I have a very strong opinion.
It all revolves overstatement 90 percent
of it revolves around Israel and
Palestine.
You have to understand that Palestinians
also bleed and that they also have a
legitimate grievance.
Israelis may also,
but Palestinians in a nutshell are being
punished for something they did not do,
which is commit the Holocaust until
Palestine or Palestinians are recognized
as having a grievance just as much as
Israelis do and until that grievance is
addressed and addressed fairly not with
walls and not with little bits of
settlements scattered across the West
Bank,
but until it is equitably and fairly
finalized,
you will not.
You will not have peace.
It will take Israel pulling back to the
1967 borders halting further settlement
building,
allowing Palestinian refugees to return.
That's what it will take.
That proposal has been on the table
since 2002 from the Arab League and the
Organization of Islamic Conference.
In exchange for that,
every country in both of those
organizations will recognize Israel and
will open up full diplomatic relations
with them.
Six years.
That proposal has been on the table.
Israel has refused.
It's certainly a sympathetic Palestine.
It's certainly,
you know,
when Israel helicopter's fire rockets
into some street and kill six people,
including a Hamas activist that is
reported that Israel killed six people,
including one activist as opposed to say
CNN or Fox,
which will report that Israel killed
them,
Hamas activist,
and not mention those other people.
But yes,
there are front page photos,
you know,
almost every day of the latest outrage.
It's certainly skewed.
I agree with that.
But you have to look at,
you know,
who is doing,
who is committing,
frankly,
the majority of the violence since 1988.
I don't remember the statistics exactly,
but something like 10 Palestinians have
been killed for every Israeli.
Uh,
raise your hand if you've read that in
the US newspaper lately.